j'ai trompé qu'une seule fois dans ma
vie ma wii ouais je me suis grillé par
ma meuf en fait j'étais âge était une
terrasse de café avec une autre fille
elle m'a vue elle m'a dit guillaume
c'est toi j'ai dit non c'est quelqu'un
de
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non
c'est toi
très sûr de soi ouais alors il me tutoie
frontale c'est quelqu'un de bien mais
c'est toi millau non c'est quelqu'un
d'autre
génial un
homme qui a trompé 5 546 fois ses ex
épouse en leur faisant douze enfants
chacune est obligé d'animer le 6 à 7 sur
on embrasse moi jamais
vrai ou faux un homme s'était grillé la
télé par sa femme alors qu'il assistait
à un match de foot avec sa mère
dans l'écran ça voilà mais ça et en plus
et ils ont ils embrassent et après tu as
vu on voit effet genre et à chaud
connaît pas
et quelle idée d'aller dans un match de
foot rediffuser la télé oui mais il se
dit qu'il soit démis les et qui n'est
pas connu
régulièrement roland garros ça se passe
régulièrement demandant aux chefs de
service qui m'avait demandé de mentir
pour lui pour le protéger en disant je
suis allé ailleurs et je dis maintenant
site à roland garros cet après midi ça
va la [ __ ] malindi même femme regarde
jamais le tennis pas de bol et la
regarde de l'utiliser qu'est ce qu'elle
a vu sur l'écran lui
on est contre l europe va commencer on
sera encore
c'est fou à cette sale histoire comme l
histoire et surtout que c'est moi
qu'elle engageait à wemmel jeu c'est bon
c'est bon
à tout va tout on a tous michel ce que
vous avez déjà voilà non bien sûr
antilles en sommes même avant même avant
il ya très longtemps non non mais jamais
vous savez maintenant j'aime jamais un
homme et femme franchement non kenny oui
alors moi je suis partie au restaurant
avec son meilleur ami ouais et on est
arrivé à là où il fallait payer et on
était avec la femme de mon meilleur ami
et la dame à la casse a dit à bas coûts
coûts nicolas
c'est toi sur think there la semaine
dernière
alors du coup on était un peu en panique
et moi j'ai dit non non mais tu dois te
tromper et tout haut ce que moi je la
connaissais et aime dit non non c'est
bien lui nicolas machin on s'est vus la
semaine dernière donc du coup ben on a
on a fait croire à la bad et je peux pas
le dire en fait oui
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
à
la voulait la famille d'isabelle
mergault est en fait c'est une sorte de
fouet à bravo on a demandé à la personne
qu'elle aille dire que s'était trompé en
fait est que c'était un autre nicolas
bien sûr pas choisi la meilleure
histoire récente saliou diouf
ça veut bien le voir annoncer pas un
patois
collombat guillaume sétois non c'est
quelqu'un d'autre
elle m'a cru il ya un petit moment de
flottement après les parties non marek
bonne humeur 6 2
mais j'ai vu que semble oui
elle m'a dit j'ai vu quelqu'un qui
trouve semblait et je vais chez le
coiffeur j'ai changé ma vie sort
légèrement la couleur de cheveux le soir
même ouais là ça va pas là ça va sinon
un médicament pour le reste
sortir de cette maudite des
périodes compliquées un jeune sétois
raymond toi te dis encore une histoire
moi j'ai pas eu d'histoire mais j'étais
avec un pote il a une histoire de taré
mais sans aller raconte nous ton
histoire
une histoire de tard il avait une
maîtresse et elle a changé ta fille
savait pas qu'elle avait changé taf et
il va au resto avec tout le monde en
famille et tous nous on était là il nous
invite au restaurant mange de la viande
et tous et c'est sa maîtresse qui nous a
servi à table pendant tout le dîner
pendant tout le dîner il est en train de
me dire elle va lâcher la barre a lâché
le dos ça va acheter le dos et là ils
flippent est à chaque fois que j'ai des
allusions sur sa vie et des allusions
sur sur ses performances et où il était
en panique les mecs vous avez monté
cette histoire quand non alors là tout
de suite c'est l'histoire vraie de mr
jack si tu veux tu te fait servir un
jour par un mec ça et à sa maîtresse qui
vient et qu'il sert t'es pas bien
pendant une heure au restaurant de
camden savez qu'il ya un surprise
surprise qui a jamais pu assez peu moins
parce qu'on tire sur tout ce qui a
jamais pu diffuser parce que c'était un
collégien célèbre qui était à qui on
faisait de la surprise et c'est sa femme
qui servait déguisés et l'udps est
arrivé en retard il est arrivé en disant
[ __ ] je viens de bourret
anna et ses copains me disent ah non
mais non les ans tu plaisantes et lui
c'est un mec je vous ai connu - team ico
ça je voulais vous attend est là et
s'attaque bonne femme a fini par jeter
me mets sur la nourriture sur la table
et partie du coup ils ont jamais
diffusés se faire plaisir avec les
pêcheurs non non il est aujourd'hui van
hamme est un grand de l'activité avant
l'activité batteries